We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21centry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If you were standing in the crowd for any of the presidential inaugurations from Andrew Jackson through Dwight D. Eisenhower, you'd have seen the solemn oath of office taken between 24
我们得到了全球知名大学加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，该校致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、环境和教育领域最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州及全球各地合作创新，寻找变革性的解决方案。这完全符合该大学促进所有生物生活质量的宗旨。请访问 21centry.ucdavis.edu 了解更多信息。这里是“百分之九十九隐形”。我是罗曼·马斯。如果你曾站在从安德鲁·杰克逊到德怀特·D·艾森豪威尔历任总统就职典礼的人群中，你会看到庄严的宣誓仪式在
tall smooth columns at the East Portico of the United States Capitol Building. When the columns were installed in 1824, the sandstone slabs themselves that made up the columns even before they were erected were considered so important that they were transported from the were considered so important that they were transported from the Potomac River to Capitol Hill by human power alone. No lowly mules were deemed fit to move such sacred objects. But they didn't have quite the same standing in 1958.
美国国会大厦东门廊的24根高大光滑的圆柱之间举行。当这些圆柱于1824年安装时，甚至在它们竖起之前，构成圆柱的砂岩石板本身就被认为极其重要，以至于它们仅靠人力就从波托马克河运到了国会山。人们认为任何卑微的骡子都不配搬运如此神圣的物件。但在1958年，它们的地位就不完全一样了。
They had been taken off the east front when the east front was extended. They were stored down along the Potomac and created slowly disintegrating. After the renovation of the capital, the columns all got the boot. The notion was horrifying to Ethel Garrett, and she conscripted her friend Betty Ray. I'm Elizabeth C. Ray known as Betty Ray. And sometime in the 1970s, they made it their mission to get the columns back on their feet. I thought this would be very simple. I mean, who would say, you know, couldn't do this? It turns out plenty of people stood in the way.
当东门廊扩建时，它们被从东立面拆除了。它们被储存在波托马克河沿岸，并逐渐开始风化解体。国会大厦翻新后，这些圆柱全都被抛弃了。埃塞尔·加雷特对这种想法感到惊恐，她拉上了她的朋友贝蒂·雷。我是伊丽莎白·C·雷，人称贝蒂·雷。在20世纪70年代的某个时候，她们把让这些圆柱重新站起来作为她们的使命。我以为这会很简单。我的意思是，谁会说，你知道的，做不到这一点呢？事实证明，有很多人挡了道。
Technically, they still belonged to Congress. And after 10 years of meetings, you had to appear before various committees. And more meetings. And then they would have another meeting. Fun raising. I had to appear before the National Capital Planning Commission. And hiring architects and surveyors.
从技术上讲，它们仍然属于国会。经过十年的会议，你必须出席各种委员会。还有更多的会议。然后他们会开另一个会议。筹款。我不得不出席国家首都规划委员会的听证会。还要聘请建筑师和测量师。
I learned a tremendous amount of bureaucracy. The columns were moved from storage. From the area along the Potomac, they were put on trailers and strapped with bands of steel things on mattresses, old mattresses, and they have then brought to the National Arboretum. The Arboretum is a swath of greenery nestled in among the warehouses and gas stations at the edge of Washington, D.C. It's where the old columns of the U.S. Capitol still are today. When you're walking up to the columns located on a high area in the meadow of the Arboretum,
我学到了大量的官僚作风。这些圆柱被从储藏处移走。从波托马克河沿岸的地区，它们被装上拖车，用钢带固定在床垫上，旧床垫上，然后被带到国家植物园。植物园是一片夹在华盛顿特区边缘的仓库和加油站之间的绿地。美国国会大厦的旧圆柱今天仍然在那里。当你走向位于植物园草地高处的圆柱时，
they're majestic, They're huge columns. They, of course, are freestanding. They are really majestic. And there's only one way to describing it. Majestic. I could see them approaching from the field and they actually are pretty majestic. The consensus seems to be that they look pretty majestic.
它们雄伟壮观，是巨大的圆柱。当然，它们是独立矗立的。它们真的很雄伟。而且只有一种方法可以形容它。雄伟。我可以看到它们从田野里走近，它们实际上非常雄伟。大家的共识似乎是它们看起来非常雄伟。
It's pretty spectacular. That's radio producer Jess Shribstein checking out the columns at the National Arboretum. So to my right on the crest of this very small hill are I want to guess to me a couple dozen columns. I think it's 22. Withers Chrissie Moore she works at the Arboretum. So they have Corinthian tops on these columns and they're lined up in a few rows, very tall. I understand why people think that they're from Greece or from Rome because it actually looks like
这相当壮观。那是广播制作人杰丝·施里布斯坦在国家植物园查看圆柱的情况。所以在我的右边，在这个非常小的小丘的顶端，我想大概有几十根圆柱。我认为是22根。克里西·莫尔在植物园工作。所以这些圆柱的顶部有科林斯式的柱头，它们排成几行，非常高。我理解为什么人们认为它们来自希腊或罗马，因为它们实际上看起来像
some old Greek ruins sitting on top of a hill. A definite distinct grandeur about it that you won't see much outside of Washington, DC. Independent of their grand presentation, the columns hold a certain power. Even if they don't hold a roof, but not all of the old East Puerto Rico had a champion like Betty Ray. My directions say, go downhill into the woods. Go down towards the bottom of the hill. There
一些古老的希腊遗址坐落在山顶上。它有一种明确而独特的宏伟感，你在华盛顿特区以外很难看到。除了宏观的展示之外，这些圆柱还拥有某种力量。即使它们没有支撑屋顶，但并非所有的旧东门廊都有像贝蒂·雷这样的支持者。我的路线说明是，下山进树林。向山脚下走去。那里
will be no trail. Don't worry. Keep walking. Several miles away from the National Arboretum, where there's no visitor center, there are no commemorative blacks. Then there'll be at the bottom of the hill, there'll be a trail that goes up into a ravine. And you go on that trail, and then at a large concrete bridge, take the lower fork to pass under the bridge, and then there's a clearing on the left.
将没有小路。别担心。继续走。距离国家植物园几英里远的地方，那里没有游客中心，也没有纪念标牌。然后到了山脚下，会有一条通往峡谷的小路。你走那条小路，然后在座大混凝土桥处，走下方的岔路从桥下穿过，左边有一片空地。
Are you coming by? And here in the middle of the woods lies the rest of the capital's east portico, the parts that didn't make it to the arboretum. To the right of us are basically stacks and stacks of columns that we almost could have walked right by. I feel like I could have walked right by not even seen them. Yeah.
你来过吗？而在树林的中央，躺着国会大厦东门廊的其余部分，也就是那些没有进入植物园的部分。在我们的右边基本上是一叠又一叠的圆柱，我们几乎差点就从它们旁边走过去了。我觉得我差点就从它们旁边走过去甚至都没看到它们。是的。
They're next to some buildings, so it looks like it could just be, you know, part of some building materials, but if you look at it more closely, you see that they are actually kind of moss covered and do look rather ancient. This place is 100 square yards of busted up architecture, mounds of stone and granite and decapitated heads of Corinthian columns weathering in the snow. But its arrangement is oddly intentional, with bits of building carefully stacked 12-15 feet high with wells and chasm spanning between. Is it? They're just going to leave them here?
它们挨着一些建筑，所以看起来可能只是，你知道的，某些建筑材料的一部分，但如果你仔细看，你会发现它们其实有点长满苔藓，而且看起来确实相当古老。这个地方有100平方码破碎的建筑，成堆的石头、花岗岩以及科林斯式柱头在雪中风化的断头。但它的排列出奇地带有某种意图，建筑物的碎片被仔细堆叠到12到15英尺高，中间有水井和深谷横跨。是吗？他们就要把它们留在这里吗？
It seems kind of sad. They are the physical manifestation of the parts of history that didn't make the cut. They do look a bit sad. They look pretty dejective. Wow. Okay. It's kind of cool. history that didn't make the cut. They do look a bit sad. They look pretty dejective. Wow. OK. It's kind of quite a clam up here.
这看起来有点悲伤。它们是历史上未能入选的部分的物质实体化。它们确实看起来有点悲伤。它们看起来相当沮丧。哇。好吧。这挺酷的。历史上未能入选的部分。它们确实看起来有点悲伤。它们看起来相当沮丧。哇。好吧。这里相当安静。
Whoa. This one's wobbly. But even here, without the rolling meadow and historic backdrop, the ruin still managed to be majestic. I think if I discovered this and I or the kid, I would have felt like I discovered the lost world. Yeah, I feel the little like it land is.
哇。这个有点摇晃。但即使在这里，没有了连绵起伏的草地和历史背景，这些废墟依然设法显得雄伟。我想如果我发现了这个，我或者如果我是个小孩，我会觉得自己发现了失落的世界。是的，我觉得有点像它是一片土地。
This episode of 99% Invisible was produced by me, Roman Mars with Sam Greenspan and Jess Shrikes Roman Mars, with Sam Green's fan and Jess Shrikes' Dine, with help from Melissa Lee and John Asante. Before them have their own fledgling podcasts called Whispersitties, learn more at Whispersitties.org. This program is made possible with support from Lunar, making a difference with creativity. It's a project of KALW, the American Institute of Architect San Francisco in the Center for Architecture and Design. Project of KALW, the American Institute of Architect San Francisco in the Center for Architecture and Design.
这期《百分之九十九隐形》由我罗曼·马斯与萨姆·格林斯潘和杰丝·施里克斯制作，梅丽莎·李和约翰·阿桑特提供了帮助。在此之前，他们有自己的萌芽播客叫Whispersitties，请在Whispersitties.org了解更多信息。本节目由Lunar赞助播出，Lunar用创意创造不同。这是KALW、美国建筑师学会旧金山分会以及建筑与设计中心的合作项目。
More including cool pictures of big columns at 99%invisible.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
更多内容包括大圆柱的酷炫图片，请访问 99%invisible.org。你 本集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。